[Music]
black Christmas so black Christmas is a
remake of a remake or the second remake
of the original basically there's a
black Christmas in the 70s and another
one in the 2000s and never saw either so
now I saw this one I feel like I started
black Christmas off on the wrong foot I
shouldn't have started here from the
trailer you get the Jess Arthur says
killer on this college campus and these
sorority sisters are gonna turn the
tables and of course I mean they're
gonna take out the killer right kind of
it's not really that though because
nothing happens like nothing at a point
I checked my watch and it was about an
hour since the start time of the movie
so we'll say 20 minutes for trailers so
40 minutes into the movie maybe 45
nothing had happens I mean someone dies
in the beginning in a very uninteresting
way but since then you're just you're
getting inundated with the movies like
fight the patriarchy social message I
mean a movie can have a social message I
have seen it happen I have seen it
happen very recently and I've seen it
work as long as you have interesting
characters good pacing intrigue you know
an interesting movie at the core you can
make it work but this movie doesn't do
that this movie isn't a movie with a
social message attached to it it's a
social message with a movie attached to
it and usually when I'm reviewing a
movie that has a social or political
message I push that to the side I just
stick in the pocket of the movie like
okay how was the movie how was the plot
how was the acting but this movie
mistakes social message for plot and
character development so I can't it's
what the movie is in that I feel like
you're gonna walk out of this movie
going alright that message hit me to my
core and that's enough to keep the movie
afloat I dug it or it's not gonna hit
you and you're gonna walk out gone the
movie was bad because the movie will
it's the opposite of good I mean the
killer element in this movie was
completely weak whenever there was a
killer which is kind of like a killer
and then the scene was done it wasn't
interesting there was no tension it just
kind of happened it's less of a slasher
movie more of a really boring murder
mystery and this movie actually has a
few social message doesn't just have one
it has this one this one that one it has
a few this movie has got to be the
prettiest preachy movie I've ever seen
preach to me the movie the characters
the plot the pacing that has to come
first if you can have your message in
there fine but subtlety is key this has
all the subtlety of the social media it
was bred off of at best you're gonna
feel like you unwittingly got dragged to
a March while hanging out with your
friends that you didn't really think you
were gonna go to today at worst you're
gonna feel like this movie is clubbing
you over the head with its point
so much it feels like a [ __ ] Quan Chi
fatality it's the only movie where I'm
like maybe the movie just wasn't made
for me maybe there's some validity to
that statement I've never really
subscribed to that statement before I
still actually don't this is the first
time I've ever been like should I even
review it I I don't know but I want to
talk about it anyway because sometimes
good decision-making and me were just
ships passing in the night
also the movies not good just as a
horror movie it was boring nothing
happened as a social justice movie I was
like are they trying to be a caricature
I I don't know because the movie feels
like it's trying to give a legit attempt
at being compelling and clever the
execution of dialog and situations in
this movie just comes across as
cartoonish it's so ridiculous with this
execution that it blunts any impact the
movie might have had or might have made
if it had a sprinkle of nuance if I'm
engaging social media I feel like people
are wound pretty tight and they're
pretty quick to argue so if you're gonna
take this on I feel like you just need
you know better writing and when the
plot you know you get your revelations
at the end I was like is this what the
original was like because it does seem
like a 1970s horror movie plot it also
seems like a 2019 horror movie plot so I
don't know what that says you have a
boring movie with really bland
characters terrible dialogue a couple of
neat moments of imagery but in the end
just a boring flat slasher flick that
really isn't a slasher flick black
Christmas is masquerading as something
deeper with all the subtlety of a
chainsaw it tries but in the end it's
just another lazy boring [ __ ] horror
movie alright so black Christmas have
you seen it what did you think about it
or are you gonna say it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]